je n'ai jamais fait des enfants pour
l'amour de l'homme qui partageait ma vie
parce que je voulais absolument un
enfant de lui et bien souvent j'ai fait
mes enfants il est vrai quand déjà
l'amour était passé alors Lio vrai nom
tout le monde le sait maintenant Vanda
je vous appelle Vanda ou Lio d'ailleurs
pour cet entretien euh appelez-moi Lio
tout de même nous sommes quand même dans
le domaine public écoutez c'est très
schizophrène quand vous par parler de la
vie privée appelez-moi Vanda dès que
vous passez à la vie publique
appelez-moi je vais avoir du mal à à m'y
retrouver je pense ai donc on fait
simple lo lo une carrière très bien
remplie depuis que vous êtes alors très
jeune avec banana split les textes de
prévers chantés par vous carrière aussi
remplie de comédienne et même enceinte
de votre 6e enfant donc vous étiez
encore pratiquement allz à 15 jours de
l'accouchement sur sur les planches j'ai
vécu une grosse décennie vraiment
extrêmement difficile où où le boulot
n'arrivait pas du tout quand on a la
chance de presque renaître grâce grâce à
aux chansons de prév qu'il y a une
tournée qui
est qui est faite et qu'on tombe
enceinte et que c'est quand même
magnifique onannule pas toutes les dates
parce qu'avec la réputation que j'ai si
j'annule les dates je vais encore
attendre 10 ans avant mon prochain
contrat risque impossible à prendre
quand on a autant d'enfants que moi il
faut que le travail arrive alors si
enfants B oui c'est elle est réaliste
elle est très réaliste six enfants ce
qui est une famille aujourd'hui
absolument colossal de quatre pères
différents en général ce sont les hommes
qui se comportent comme ça Lio mes
enfants ont été toujours des appels de
la
vie si c'est ça se comporter comme un
homme
je vous assure je n'ai pas une paire de
couill mais souvent souvent un
comportement quand même de de
provocation et c'est certainement ça
qu'on me reproch je te manque de
moralité moi je ne trouve pas avoir
manqué de moralité vous dites qu'il
n'est pas indispensable d'aimer l'homme
avec lequel on conçoit un bébé oui ce
que je dis c'est que je n'ai jamais fait
des enfants pour la amour de l'homme qui
partageait ma vie parce que je voulais
absolument un enfant de lui et que ça
allait consolider notre amour et bien
souvent j'ai fait mes enfants il est
vrai quand déjà l'amour était passé je
restais parce que je me disais quelque
chose de formidable va nous arriver qui
va ramener l'amour mais je dis je n'ai
pas fait d'enfant par amour du père avec
qui je les ai conçu c'est vrai sauf le
dernier alors le dernier est un cas
particulier effectivement
c'est vrai et quand même avec un grand
amour on y reviendra puisque c'est un
amour de jeunesse que que vous avez
petit am et voilà que que vous venez de
retrouver et on vous sent pour une fois
sereine Lio je
l'aime ça fait plaisir à entendre on
essae ça c'est quelque chose que parfois
vous vous regrettez de de les avoir
amené dans des histoires qui ont été
parfois douloureuses pour vous avec les
pères des
enfants c'est difficile je je écoutez
oui je il y a quand même une histoire
extrêmement violente que j'ai vécu dans
ma vie où je regrette oui je regrette
parce que parce qu'une enfant peut pas
être dans la chambre à côté de celle de
sa mère et entendre un homme la taper et
lui profférer des menaces de mort moi je
ne pensais pas qu'elle qu'elle qu'elle
entendait et en fait elle entendait elle
ne me l'a jamais dit mais elle a demandé
un portable cette année-là et paraî-il
elle passait la journée à demander de
mes nouvelles à tous les gens qu'ell
savaient autour de moi je trve c'est un
poids tellement énorme que oui oui je je
oui je regrette je regrette ça c'est
pour ça que vous avez écrit lo et que
vous parlez en général que vous
témoignez justement sur aussi les
violences conjugal j'ai pas écrit cette
histoire à cause de cet épisode brutal
et violent de ma vie j'ai accepté de
parler des violences conjugales que j'ai
subi pas par choix ça m'a été imposé
vous savez que la correctionnelle c'est
ouvert au public il y a des mouchards
c'est comme ça moi j'avais pas alerté la
presse vous savez très bien je ne
trouvais pas ça extrêmement glamour de
m'être retrouver finalement au
commissariat avec un nez cassé et cinq
vertèbres déplacées euh de devant
quitter la maison en pleine nuit dans le
panier à salade avec les enfants parce
qu'à l'époque la loi voulait que c'était
les femmes qui devaient quitter le
domicile même si elles étaient victimes
de coup et le lendemain je vois deux
pages enfin deux colonnes à la une
racontant l'histoire je ne savais pas ça
je pensais que c'était vous qui aviez
choisi de médiatiser pas du tout pas du
tout avec cette histoire douloureuse
hein cette relation violente refaire un
enfant c'était à Paris incroyable on
peut après tout ça se dire avoir peur
quand même des hommes j'ai eu surtout
peur de moi c'était moi que je voulais
comprendre je voulais comprendre comment
le processus c'est ça qui était
important vous avz accepté oui et le
livre de Marie-France Irigoyen sur le
harcèlement moral m'a énormément aidé et
après on se reconstruit la vie n'est
jamais finie et du pire on peut faire le
meilleur alors ce désir d'enfant sans
cesse renouvelé il vient d'où vous dites
à un moment donné que chaque histoire de
cœur vous éloignnez un peu plus de de
vous de Vanda donc et que les enfants
servait à rééquilibrer les choses oui je
me suis dit ça parce que
finalement Lio est à mes côtés depuis
que j'ai 16
ans les hommes que j'ai rencontré à
partir de cet âge là de mes 16 ans c'est
lo qu'il voyait et donc effectivement il
tombait amoureux de lo Vanda les
intéressait assez peu et ils se sont
tout d'un coup frotté à Vanda et ça ça
ça a été compliqué c'est pour ça que je
dis chaque histoire d'amour m'éloignait
un petit peu plus de Vanda l'image de
d'une petite on va dire allez
Starlett très joli fil sexy et Vanda
c'était la rebelle tuétait EVANDA est
quelqu'un de plus complexe que ça
quelqu'un qui a qui est une exilée qui
qui vient d'une famille de très fortte
personnalité quand vous dites donc dans
dans pop model que votre enfance a été
pillée oui je pense que que qu' a eu
qu'il a eu un pillage c'est-à-dire que
jamais je n'ai vu une personne se
dire qu'ils avaient une enfant en face
d'eux
donc pas d'adolescence en fait oui c'est
l'enfance ou l'adolescence c'est
l'adolescence et c'est et l'enfance je
parle de mon enfance pillée parce que
quand on est quand on est un moment de
sa vie le jeu d'un concours entre un
père et une mère un père qui qui va
vient vous chercher un après-midi qui
vous ramène pas le soir qui vous fait
plus voir votre mère c'est un rapte pour
bien comprendre he l je vous arrête une
seconde c'est ce que vous racontez
puisque vous êtes arraché donc par votre
père à votre mère qui se sépare c'est ça
d'abord dans un premier temps en fait il
se sépare et il il il estime que tout va
bien à partir du moment où elle reste
seule et quand ma mère décide de refaire
sa vie alors ça ça va plus du tout tant
qu'elle était seule il acceptait la
séparation mais ah il y avait un autre
alors ça n'allait plus plus plus plus du
toutà partir de là je me suis retrouvée
effectivement dans une histoire assez
lourde à dire vrai euh mon père savait
que ce qui allait toucher énormément ma
mère ben c'était à travers ses enfants
et donc il est allé au tribunal avec
adultère constaté et elle a perdu le
droit sur ses enfants jusqu'au jour où
ma mère a décidé qu'elle qu'elle allait
partir avec moi ailleurs pour que ça
s'arrête j'étais en souffrance ouais
mais vous vous avez vécu en plus après
avec un un beau-père qui vous a beaucoup
aimé tout à fait donc vous avez retrouvé
de l'amour de la stabilité et oui puis
j'ai vu une j'ai vu une mère qui qui qui
qui s'était positionnée qui avait fait
des choix qui les avait assumés qui
étaient partis sans rien dire à personne
dans un pays inconnu d'elle c'est des
c'est des leçons de vie extraordinaire
moi je je voudrais changer ma vie pour
rien au monde pouvant plus exercer son
métier comme votre beau-père hein ils
sontement elle elle était elle était
étudiante en philosophie et lettrre
évidemment elle a elle a été
serveuseemme de ménage enfin comme on
était d'une famille de médecin la vie
était plutôt douce au Portugal elle
était pas compliquée donc vous avez
quand même de qui tenir
sûrement qu'est-ce que vous dites de
votre mère qu'elle a un tempérament fort
pour le moi ma mère c'est de l'amour
c'est une femme d'une générosité
incroyable et votre Père qui est décédé
oui est-ce que comme le disait c'est
Jean-François c'est vous qui le disez
tout à l'heure Jean-François Carmet
est-ce que c'est une façon de de lui
parler aussi à travers le livre vous
savez j'ai absolument pas de douleur par
rapport à mon père et et Lio avec
l'image donc que le le père absent
pouvait être un schéma qu'on avait pas
forcément besoin d'un d'un père pour
grandir ou quand même un manque on
besoin on a besoin d'un père pour
grandir c'est que ce soit le père qui
qui géniteur ou que ce soit ou que ce
soit un autre père oui oui moi je me
suis beaucoup beaucoup formé et à à mon
beau-père et à mon père aussi parce que
je me suis posé énormément de
questions sur lui et que j'ai je l'ai
revu quand même nous avons eu une
relation elle est ce qu'elle est mais
nous avons une relation mais mais parce
qu'on a le sentiment hein quand on quand
on vous voit dans votre vie familiale
c'est important les enfants connaissent
leur père évidemment mais que le père
n'a que sa f enfin une fonction qui lu
imp partie vous vous trompez vous vous
trompez vraiment non non les les moi les
pères je je trouve qu'ils sont
extrêmement importants je leur donne
tout la place possible si ce n'est celle
que je ne peux plus leur donner parce je
ne peux plus partager leur vie mais non
pas du tout donc l'h est bienvenu il
est il est
extril il est extrêmement bienvenu
extrêmement
bienvenu pourquoi qu'est-ce que vous
pensz n'aimait pas les hommes non parce
que je sais pas ou alors je je cherche
je suis un peu compliqué mais pour moi
d'avoir un
enfant j'ai eu des enfants je les ai
fait par amour et moi aussi plein
d'amour avec la femme avec qui à
l'époque j'étais c'est votre trajet moi
je vous explique que dans mon cas ce
n'était pas exactement ça voilà comme
avoir des pères ENF des pères des hommes
qui font un enfant un certain âge je
citerai pas de nom
mais moi déjà faire personnellement
parce que je trouve que PAP il avait
quel â il avit 51a en plus il est parti
j'étais mou et je peux vous dire que
donc vous vous êtes ouais vous êtes pour
un schéma plus plus ah bah pour moi
c'est ou oui parce que attendez on
souffre tellement est-ce que vous pensez
que le comportement de Lo est un
comportement égoïste excusez-moi mais
est-ce que vous pensez à eux aux enfants
je n'ai pensé qu'à eux et je je j'ai
rarement été j'ai été seule pendant des
moments mais mon grand désir était de ne
pas rester dans cette famille
monoparentale j'ai le désir de vivre la
preuve de vivre avec quelqu'un la preuve
rencontrer Jean-Pierre qui est l'homme
invisible Jean-Pierre donc votre nouveau
compagnon qui qui ne veut justement pas
être he sous le feu des des médias vous
l'avez connu quand il avait 12 ans vous
en aviez j'avais 12 aussi on é 62 tous
les deux ça c'est quand même le Il a
décrété que j'étais la femme de sa vie
qui aurait jamais
d'autres et 28 ans après il est revenu
dans ma vie alors que vous ne vous étiez
plus revu pratiquement par petit bout
comme ça mais d'une comme si la vie
voulait toujours nous redonner un petit
un petit signe mais où rien ne s'était
passé et je viens avec lui ça va faire 3
ans et comment vous êtes alors
aujourd'hui avec vous-même est-ce que
Lio Vanda ont fait la paix est-ce que
vous êtes la même j'ai mis beaucoup
d'années parce que je je je je ne je
suis entière comme ça d'un bloc et je
n'avais pas du tout enfin pour moi
c'était évident que ce que les gens
voyaient c'était Vanda j'ai pas une
seconde c'est une bêtise totale je
l'avoue mais c'est vrai que j'ai mis de
nombreuses années à m'apercevoir que non
que c'était lo alors alors j'en ai tenu
compte d'avoir pu le nommer j'en ai tenu
compte je m'en sors beaucoup mieux j'ai
compris beaucoup beaucoup de choses
aussi et j'ai surtout appris euh et ça
c'est un long travail à me déterminer
n'est pas en je ne veux pas ça mais en
je veux
ça pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne in
Mireille Duma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche